morning everyone we start with breaking
news on inflation we've just had the
figures uh within the last few seconds
bad news back to double digits let's
find out more Paul is standing by for us
in The Newsroom um hi Paul what's the
latest
yeah good morning Kate uh CPI Consumer
Price inflation has risen again in
August it's back above 10 news today it
has risen to 10.1 percent from the
August number of 9.9 that takes it back
to where it was in July itself a figure
that was last higher in the early 1990s
so close to record highs for inflation
10.1 that means obviously bad news for
consumers the cost of living squeeze is
going to continue it tells us it is
continuing is likely to continue the
biggest driver of this increase in
inflation according to the office for
National statistics is food prices food
inflation that is a combination of both
the input costs the cost of importing
many of the raw materials and the basic
Commodities on which our food is based
as well as transport costs while fuel
prices are dropping back it is still
very expensive to move Goods around the
country and there is plenty of evidence
reflected in these figures that
supermarkets and other retailers are
passing on these costs now to Consumers
but the other place apart from every
household in the country where this will
be watched is of course in Whitehall we
have a new chance of the exchequer
attempting to balance the books and this
figure matters today the 10.1 percent
inflation figure for September matters
because it is the figure against which
pensions and benefits will be uprated if
big if the conservative party and the
government sticks to its Manifesto
pledge but that is now in play so 10.1
an extremely high inflation figure and
an expression of the reality of the cost
of living squeeze for everyone in the UK
okay thanks very much James clavey
foreign secretary here with us for
immediate reaction to that so pensions
and benefits going up by at least 10
percent
well we've seen those inflation figures
obviously the chancellor is going to be
making a statement to the house in just
over a week's time the decisions that he
and the treasury team will be making
will be very much informed by those
figures but boring though that is okay
you know that I'm not going to be
pre-announcing any of the measures that
might come in that statement on the 31st
but you promised
government you promised in your
Manifesto well look we do take Manifesto
commitments incredibly seriously as you
know
um and uh and those figures of course
are concerning but they are similar to
in fact in some instances significantly
lower than inflation figures we're
seeing in many other parts of the
developed world as I say the the charts
from his team will be using those
figures to do their thinking and we'll
be coming up with a full packet of
measures the full details all the things
that your viewers will want to know
about in just over a week's time and
that's when the the announcements on
these and other things will be put in
the public domain yeah but as a
Manifesto promised that you would
increase benefits and pensions in line
with inflation yeah and as I say we take
Manifesto commitments seriously what I'm
not going to do what I'm not going to do
is pre-announce budget measures these
figures will be taken into consideration
by the chancellor and the team and as I
say in a little over a week's time
they'll be making a statement of the
house with a full range of financial
measures okay
um
45p down to 40p back up to 45p 19p up to
20p corporation tax going up to 25
percent uh public spending issues there
energy price guarantee that's been
changed as well what's the point of
listros well what we've got to remember
is that we are facing an unprecedented
set of circumstances but the Prime
Minister was absolutely clear and I
think when I came on the show last time
I said she's absolutely clear that what
we ultimately have to do is grow the
economy and she's still very much
committed to that she said that she
wanted to protect families and
businesses that were facing potentially
huge uh energy price increases this
winter and she's done that those were
the main measures from that but she's
also said that she uh we made mistakes
she's sought to address those uh
Jeremy's now come in as Chancellor he
has made changes to make sure that we
can reassure the international financial
markets on which we like every other
developed economy relies quite heavily
for public borrowing and we've seen that
and we've seen that now have a positive
effect there is still tough times ahead
there's no doubt about that there is
going to be a tough winter for us and
countries as I say developed con
economies all economies frankly around
the world and that's what we're focusing
on to protect the people that need
protection
and to get the economy going this is
only three weeks ago I mean this is not
a U-turn this is a 10 car pile up in the
fog that's your words not mine no it is
I would tell me why it isn't well as I
say these are circumstances which are
affecting countries right across the
globe interest rates interest rates are
already interest rates are already much
higher than we see here in the UK in
other parts of the world inflation is
higher in in many other parts of the
world this is really really tough
economic headwinds But ultimately the
prime minister is still committed to
grow the economy that's what the
medium-term financial plan uh ultimately
will be uh designed to do but we've got
to recognize that the measures that we
put forward initially clearly were felt
to go too far too fast the Prime
Minister has uh has said that she's
apologized for the impact that that had
on the financial markets and the
chancellor and her are now working to
continue with that growth agenda to
continue to protect the people that need
protecting both from the economic
situation here in the UK and
ukrainians which is what I'm focused on
you know we see you know drone attacks
in Ukraine
so that's what we're focused on how many
more mistakes can she afford to make I
spoke to the Armed Forces Minister
yesterday uh James TP he said no more
mistakes
well no one wants to make mistakes how
many more could you afford to make So
the plan is not to make mistakes you
don't say well you know I've got a
certain number of mistakes that I'm
allowed to make we we don't aim to make
mistakes and and actually the the the
simple truth in life in in politics in
business in life is that mistakes happen
they do happen what you've got to do is
recognize when they've happened and have
you humility
to uh to to make changes when you see
things didn't go right it was clear that
the uh a number of the announcements
some of the announcements were not all
some of the announcements in the uh the
statement that quasi made as Chancellor
had a negative effect on markets and
we've sought to address those things so
that we can focus on as I say growing
the economy protecting people from those
Rising bills helping ukrainians protect
themselves totally ripped ripped to
shreds the plan and Jeremy Hunt has come
up with something that even uh Rishi
sunak hadn't gone that far when it came
to his Economic Policy
um Ben Wallace said that he would resign
if defense spending uh was cut what
would you resign over I'm not I'm not
I'm not discussing uh resigning because
I've got too much work to do so I I have
got to ensure that the global events are
as far as we can uh as far as we can do
those global events are addressed so
that's why I'm that's why I'm very
focused on helping ukrainians defend
themselves because Russia's attack on
Ukraine has had a huge impact on global
Energy prices
on the foreign
secretary this is literally my job to
focus on China and Ukraine and Global
food prices okay Global Energy prices
and counter-terrorism and War around the
world that is literally my job 55 think
that she should resign well we've we've
we've we've gone through quite recently
a situation where lots of people were
saying oh Boris has got to resign Boris
has got to resign and at the time I said
okay you might not be happy but what's
your plan for for what happens next and
for those people what's happening for
those people who defenestrated uh Boris
they didn't have a plan for what's
happening next they're now criticizing
the new prime minister many of the same
people criticizing the new prime
minister and I just say again look
what we need at this point is we need to
get focused on delivery delivering those
minimum service agreements so
communities can get to work delivering
the infrastructure so that we can grow
the economy deliver calm confidence to
the markets and I don't think any of
those things would be served by you
wouldn't be fine I mean if if this is
the case I mean you'll be lucky to hold
on to your position more of more of the
people who actually voted for her and I
said that they would vote for Rishi
sunak well the the the point I'm making
is that we have got to deliver when
people see governments deliver numbers
like this uh reduce and that's what the
Prime Minister said she said she is
focused on doing delivering the
infrastructure that unlocks economic
growth delivering our ongoing support
for Ukraine so that the the effects
which we're now feeling of inflation
um of of uh you know energy price Rises
and in many parts of the world food
insecurity these these things can be
addressed that's what I'm working on
that's what the Prime Minister will be
thinking about as well as the domestic
agenda as well yeah I know but you have
to have faith in your prime minister in
order to have the respect not only in
the UK but also around the world I mean
she's pmqs it's only the third one she's
done
um and last week she said no spending
cuts
um at all that's that she laughed when
um it was put to a by kierstama we now
know it could be 15 across the board
well as I say the Chance is going to be
setting out his plan next week and I'm
not going to speculate uh you've already
asked me about that but the the you know
the people who are criticizing the Prime
Minister and I and I get why people are
frustrated you know we look at poll
numbers of course it's disconcerting if
you're a member of the government but my
contention is the best way of addressing
those poll numbers is to demonstrate the
British people that we are focused on
their priorities and we're delivering on
their behalf and if we do that those
numbers will head in the right direction
instead of the wrong direction what I'm
not convinced by far far from convinced
by is that going through another
leadership campaign defenestrating
another prime minister will either
convince the British people that we're
thinking about them rather than
ourselves or convince the markets to
stay calm and and ensure things like
those bond yields and guilt yields start
coming back down
um and you know being angry I get I
totally get it but that's an emotional
response it's not a plan and the prime
minister's got a plan
we've got a prime minister and as I say
for all the reasons I've just discussed
I don't think it's a good idea to be
focused on our you know internal
frustrations and I get why people are
frustrated but rather than focusing on
our internal frustrations what we what
we should be focusing on is delivering
for them why should we believe this plan
when the last plan was rubbish
that okay the the the Prime Minister and
the chancellor have have learned lessons
from what happened previously as I said
when mistakes happen
the right thing to do is learn from them
adjust and then move forward and that's
exactly what we're doing we've got the
Ukrainian Ambassador on the program
later on um he is obviously very
concerned uh about the power stations
that are being taken out by these
airstrikes what sort of air cover are we
going to offer to them well um I uh I
spoke with my opposite a number of the
Ukrainian foreign minister yesterday who
was saying about how drones were flying
over the area that he lived
um obviously the the attacks from the
air both through missiles and drones I
think are well I know is because Russia
has failed to gain ground in the land
War it's a it's a Vicious Kind of
reprisal attack we've already supplied
uh amram
air missiles to help shoot down the uh
the cruise missiles that Russia have
been using uh we are uh we have imposed
sanctions and we'll look at sanctioning
enforcement to make sure the people
selling Russia things like those drones
uh are prevented from doing so so we
close off the supply five of those kind
of Munitions and also what we'll be
doing and I'll be speaking with my
Ukrainian counterparts just as the the
defense secretary of speaking with is
Iranian counterparts about what more we
can do to help ukrainians protect
themselves from these these vicious
attacks from the air yeah it was with
some concern that we learned that Ben
Wallace went to Washington for these
urgent talks and when we did some more
digging here at Sky News apparently
there's concern uh that Putin could be
planning a nuclear attack and that's why
Ben Wallace went to Washington to
discuss it is that the case no so so we
speak to our European counterparts on
American counterparts or Ukrainian
counterparts regularly understood and
and we do so because we've seen a shift
in tactics from Russia that they're
moving towards uh more attacks on
civilian infrastructure rather than on
Military targets so these conversations
are a are a normal and regular part of
what is frankly a very abnormal and
perverse situation had to get on a plane
to do that do you he's got a nobody
urgently no no we do we there was
nothing urgent about it so the reason we
well there's urgency because of course
there's urgency because because
civilians are being targeted in a new
way and so we have to respond to that
and our response has got to be done at
PACE and there are conversations which
frankly you don't want to have
um uh over the over the telephone but we
speak face to face with our counterparts
pretty regularly it's part of what you
know Ben and I
um and indeed the Prime Minister and
others are doing to help keep us all
safe help the ukrainians defend
themselves against Russian attacks are
you brushing aside my question about
nuclear concern well what we do is we
discuss a full range of how we help the
ukrainians to defend themselves so I'm
not at the me I'm here rather than over
in the states so I don't you know I'm
I'm not going to guess or speculate as
to exactly the things that are discussed
but the point is that distance all the
time
yeah I know I get that I get that but
the point I'm making is that we talk
about a range of issues every time we
speak uh what we are what we are seeing
in Ukraine is is brutality on a scale
that we are not used to uh in in Europe
we are seeing Putin uh put these vicious
attacks on civilian infrastructure so of
course we want to discuss uh how we help
the ukrainians about what might happen
in the future and as I say what I don't
want you to do is is focus on one
element of what would be what would be a
normal discussion from defense minutes
okay I I got a message from one of your
colleagues last night who said he he
went because
um the madman's got new because he's how
it was put well as I say we would
inevitably discuss a full range of stuff
but ultimately this is a normal part of
how close friends like the US and the UK
work to support a really good friend
like Ukraine what are we going to do
with China seeing people
um who are peacefully protesting getting
beaten up yeah that was unacceptable
that was unacceptable so I had the
Chinese charge Affair the the number two
in the Chinese Embassy uh called into
the foreign office summonsed to the
foreign
yes I did and did you speak to him no I
didn't that was done by one of my
officials
um what did you say well we said this is
absolutely unacceptable that the uh the
protests were were peaceful and legal
they were on British soil and it is
absolutely unacceptable for this kind of
behavior now the my understanding is the
greater Manchester police will be
conducting a an investigation into this
and when I see the details of that
investigation I'll then decide what more
we might need to do on that so there
could be more to be done well as I say I
will see what the greater Manchester
it's outrageous that it's unacceptable
it is unacceptable okay I'll have to let
you go it's great to see you as always
thank you thank you let's um have a look
at what the papers uh oh don't forget
pmqs actually at uh midday today here on
Sky News
um so of course you can watch that live
from midday I know that's incredibly
popular
um so do check that out uh midday today
I think it's Jane that will be taking
you through events I also want to look
at what's happening as far as the papers
excuse me are concern this morning the
Metro leads with a new poll showing that
Liz trust his popularity has dropped to
a record low of minus 70 with more than
half of Tory members wanting her to go a
quick sip of water for me excuse me
more Peril to come if she drops her
promise to protect the triple lock and
raise State pensions in line with
soaring inflation the telegraph says
abandoning the triple lock would leave
millions of pensioners out of pocket
while the Daily Express puts it in the
woods of the pension campaigners don't
dare go back on pension triple lock
according to the times the new
Chancellor may also postpone the planned
cap on social care costs and the
guardian reports of cabinet unrest after
Liz truss says toxic budget cuts
um try to get some more of that from the
foreign secretary he says we'll have to
wait and see what the chancellor has to
say the new inflation figures out
speaking to the monetary expert Andrew
sentence and to a grandma who's
struggling to care for her two young
grandchildren
to block joined by the shadow Secretary
of State for leveling up and housing
that's Lisa nandi
and as the NHS sets up War rooms to
prepare for the toughest winter on
record I'll speak to GP Dr David Lloyd
about the challenges ahead
meantime after weeks of Ukrainian
progress Russia is making some slow
gains which held notably around the
eastern city of bakmut in the danette's
region of the donbass the city remains
under Ukrainian control but is
undergoing heavy Russian bombardment uh
International correspondent John Sparks
sent this report from the front line
in the city of bakmud some days are more
difficult than others
once home to a hundred thousand people
it's now a major military objective and
this ambulance must deal with the
consequences there's smoke at the end of
the lane
far or possible fire
on the outskirts of the city the
paramedics find a woman on the ground
her chest is bleeding the tips of her
shoes torn off
she calls out to her partner
this neighborhood has been pounded by
the Russians the front line just a few
kilometers away and as the crew treat
their patient another attack begins
children
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's go
let's go we saw burning white phosphorus
above us and felt the ground shake from
multiple explosions
we ran for the car we couldn't stay any
longer
we've left the ambulance crew there with
a woman suffered what looks like serious
injuries but that area came under attack
possibly from the air maybe grab
missiles we're not sure but we couldn't
stay it just wasn't safe
we went back to the station and waited
for the paramedics they told us Rima was
in a bad way
when the missiles hit you you hit the
ground but you didn't run away
this city has been broken sliced and
pummeled in less than a month
nowhere is safe
this car was hit by an artillery shell
the body of the driver consumed by fire
come on
but there are people trying to save
what's left of this place
members of the fire department take a
dozen calls a day like this fire in a
Timber framed house The Blaze was
threatening a city neighborhood smoke is
thick but these men don't know what
caused the fire could be a Russian shell
it could be a flare dropped from a
helicopter it's an active military area
they tugged at the roof and tried to
force their way in the firefighters
worried they'd find residents trapped
inside
to survive this war many now live
underground
anybody in there I asked
nobody there
the owners have fled said another
this is a dangerous job
it is what it is
the Ukrainian Army has retaken territory
to the North and South but the situation
in bakmud is different it's the site of
some of the most ferocious fighting in
this war
Russian intentions are written on the
walls an exhibition for everyone to see
John Sparks Sky News in eastern Ukraine
well much of Ukraine is waking up to
blackouts this morning Ukraine's
president of Vladimir zielinsky says
that over the last week Russian attacks
have knocked out 30 percent of his
country's power plants what does that
all mean then data and forensics team
has taken a closer look at some of these
attacks using open source intelligence
and pleased to say that Tom is with us
now talk us through it yeah just say
open source intelligence that's using
things like satellite imagery to
understand and we have seen this
increase in attacks on energy
infrastructure actually we've been
looking at this for a long time and this
has been an energy War that's part of
the other War that's been going on so if
you want to take you through some of it
um you remember zapparigia nuclear power
plant lots of fears around that around
whether this is going to be a
chernobyl-like incident when we've been
mapping these strikes and I think we'll
be able to show you some of that what
we're seeing is rather than actually
going for the reactors itself we've seen
some smoke here on the walls
um and you can see if we use thermal
satellite imagery with that we can
understand that actually these are fires
all along it and this isn't in the main
bit of the reactors you want to you know
what's going on here actually this is
where the power lines run for this
Apparition so that supplies Ukraine with
energy that's 20 of euclides energy
before the war and they're exporting
that energy to the EU that's been taken
offline as a result because it's unsafe
to run the act so all part of that
energy war and that's the nuclear power
station in Zappa Richard there's another
new clip Power Station South Ukraine
nuclear power station we've seen that
come under attack too that's in a
different part of the country but we saw
a missile strike here that's where you
can see it on the map it's a bit further
along from zap original yeah um that's a
strike here this is a cttv image we
found posted on social media you can see
that we've Geo located that we know very
surely where that hit we've also seen
missiles if you watch on the left hand
screen that is a missile streaking
across a nuclear power plant again
worries around that but this is also
about the energy infrastructure around
the country Cardiff in the Northeast
this isn't a nuclear power plant this is
a thermal power plant but again and we
can see that it has been hit by shelling
now both sides say the other side is
doing that we can't really verify 100
what's happening but what we've seen
over the last week Vladimir Putin has
said the same thing he wants to attack
energy infrastructure he says this is
about military energy infrastructure
president zielinski saying this is an
effort to take Ukraine um offline really
as it heads into this long cold winter
that's ahead of it so a third of energy
is offline that's according to president
zielinski and we've been verifying those
attacks now the question is can Ukraine
bring that back before that winter
um but this really looks like the
attacks we've seen so far have been
mapping them a lot of them around
civilian areas this doesn't look like
military infrastructure this looks like
an attempt to intimidate the civilian
population and you have more on this at
seven o'clock tonight seven o'clock
tonight I have a full report on our
investigation over the last few months
of this okay Sensational thanks Tom
uh looking at other news for you and
Britain has told a senior Chinese
Diplomat in the UK that the right to
peaceful protest must be respected
that's after he was summoned to explain
an incident in which a protester was
seen being pulled into the grounds
of the Chinese consulates in Manchester
and then beaten
the consul General was accused of taking
part in unrest before the violence broke
out China's foreign Ministry has
disputed police reports and says the
protester entered the premises illegally
let's get more should be from our
correspondent in Beijing um Helena good
morning to you heard from our foreign
secretary a few moments ago I'm sure you
were listening not at all happy
yeah really not happy at all and I think
there's a real sense that what happened
in Manchester on Sunday developing into
a reasonably significant diplomatic
incident the foreign secretary saying to
you this morning that he has summoned
the number two in the Chinese Embassy in
London to speak to him about what
happened but there are other MPS in the
conservative party and as we're going
further some calling for the expulsion
of one of the diplomats in Manchester
who is accused of being involved in the
assault and certainly other MPS wanting
the government to go further on this
they're saying for the time being
they're going to wait for an
investigation from Manchester police to
establish the real facts of what
happened but from here in Beijing
there's been sort of denials anger as
well about the accusations from the
British government a spokesman for the
Chinese authorities in a routine press
conference yesterday he said that
troublemakers in his words entered the
consulate illegally and that the
consulate has the right to defend the
sort of diplomatic premises and
diplomatic staff there so obviously the
results of that investigation important
but it's just worth saying okay that the
context here in China this week matters
a lot what's happening this week is
What's called the Congress the party
Congress of the Chinese Communist Party
the leading party here it's essentially
a one in every five-year event where
senior leaders choose the next group of
people who will lead China it's a time
of heightened political attention there
is a lot of paranoia around things like
the covert rules really ramped up and in
a system where lower authorities are
always Under Pressure to please and be
seen to be smoothing over difficulties
and please the higher authorities there
is a lot of paranoia so that might give
a bit of a context and explain a little
bit about why such a protest outside the
consulate a Manchester was seen by the
Chinese are so egregious but clearly
everyone will be watching out for the
results of that investigation by greater
Manchester police okay thanks so much
indefinite thank you in other news and
Iranian climber who took part in an
international competition without
wearing a headscarf has arrived back in
Tehran
a large crowd gathered to welcome the 33
year old El nazrekabi who left the Asia
championship in South Korea early
despite concerns that she could face
arrest on her return earlier this
morning she told reporters that her
actions were unintentional
[Music]
if I want to explain I should say that
everything conforms to what I've
explained on the internet it was
completely unintentional I think my
Instagram story fully explained this
fortunately I came back to Iran with
peace of mind although I went through a
lot of tension and stress
so far thank God nothing has happened
and of course this is the occasion Mr
okabe is referring to it was the first
time she was seen competing without
wearing a headscarf which is the usual
requirement for any female athlete
representing Iran
the NHS is expecting its toughest winter
ever and now Health bosses have revealed
their plan to help the system cope
that includes introducing brand new
24-hour so-called War rooms which will
manage Demand by tracking bed
availability system control centers will
help hospitals work Better Together by
diverting ambulances to those with more
capacity
new respiratory infection hubs will
allow patients to receive same-day care
without having to go to hospital that's
alongside the Autumn covered booster
rollout with more than 8 million people
now eligible for a jab and there are
also plans to help people who've fallen
in their home or a care home to prevent
unnecessary trips to hospital is thought
this could save around 55 000 ambulance
trips
and as mentioned GP Dr David Lloyd will
be here to give us his thoughts on those
new messages shortly after eight o'clock
this morning
in other news at nearly 35 000 people
have made the journey across the channel
to get to the UK so far this year
Lifeboat volunteers say that they live
in constant fear of finding tens of
bodies floating in the sea on a call out
the rnli has released footage of a life
book a Lifeboat crew rescuing five
people from the English Channel who
survived here's frozen water
scared freezing and at the very edge of
life
okay without the rnli this small group
including a family of four would have
struggled to survive that perilous
crossing of the channel the Dover
lifeboats crew of volunteers are
committed to saving lives at Sea to them
there's no distinction between a
fisherman a Windsurfer or a family
who've been put aboard an unsafe vessel
by unscrupulous profiteers
with over 35
000 making the crossing so far this year
the strain on the rli is growing
their training now includes testing new
equipment designed for rescuing multiple
casualties there's a mental strain too
when compounded by what volunteers say
is an increasing trend of threats
intimidation and abuse from those who
think they shouldn't be rescuing
the Charities head of Lifeboat says
we're incredibly proud of our crews who
continue to respond to their Pages day
or night simply to help others each time
our crews are requested to launch by the
HM Coast Guard they understand the
potential human cost so leave behind
their own families and employment to go
to the aid of others this rescue was
ultimately successful all five of the
migrants thought to be from Afghanistan
survived including a 14 year old girl
and despite the threats and intimidation
from those who'd rather preserve borders
than lives the crews will keep on
putting themselves at risk in order to
save others praise the Lord Sky News
should we have a look what the weather's
dream for us this morning
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
uh if you're like me and you've got a
cold that you can't get rid of I'm
afraid this weather is not going to help
further Spells Of Wind and Rain
spreading from the Atlantic this week
but there'll be some dry interludes as
well so looking forward to those
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
hello again everybody you're watching
the breakfast show here on Sky News let
me tell you that Liz trance is expected
to defend her Premiership in the Commons
later on today amid a growing Tory
Rebellion early this hour I spoke to the
foreign secretary James cleverley of
course who told me defenestrating
another prime minister will not Inspire
Market confidence
the people who are criticizing the Prime
Minister am I and I get why people are
frustrated you know we look at poll
numbers of course it's disconcerting if
you're a member of the government but my
contention is the best way of addressing
those poll numbers is to demonstrate to
the British people that we are focused
on their priorities and we're delivering
on their behalf and if we do that those
numbers will head in the right direction
instead of the wrong direction what I'm
not convinced by far far from convinced
by is that going through another
leadership campaign defenestrating
another prime minister will either
convince the British people that we're
thinking about them rather than
ourselves or convince the markets to
stay calm and and ensure things like
those bond yields and guilt yields start
coming back down
well at midday the unbattled MP will
face MPS at Prime Ministers questions
it'll be her statement in Parliament
since icing the chancellor first one
actually and reversing almost all of her
mini budget just after that labor will
use its opposition day debate to bring
forward a binding Motion in the House of
Commons that would ban fracking a policy
of the trust government that's unpopular
even with some of our own MPS then at
five o'clock the influential Tory back
bench 1922 committee will meet
foreign
standing by for us this morning hi uh
tomorrow in Downing a street again where
we've been for most of the week uh what
did you make of what James cleverly had
to say
morning Kay well James cleverly there
making the case for the defense saying
to MPS we get rid of Liz trust you might
actually make things worse but
conservatives know that as Liz truss
heads into what's only her third ever
prime minister's questions it could be a
humiliating one which further saps her
Authority just a week ago she was
sitting there in the Commons with a
different Chancellor a totally different
economic plan and she laughed absolutely
not when asked when if public spending
cuts were on the cards now she's junked
that whole plan junked her Chancellor as
well and conceded to MPS last night that
painful spending decisions will have to
be taken adding to her Grim poll ratings
with the public we even heard yesterday
that conservative party members the
people who put her here in number 10 now
have buyer's remorse and wish that they
had picked Rishi sunak instead a
majority of them now think the Prime
Minister should resign the general
consent to someone conservatives I've
spoken to is that getting a new
Chancellor and changing her plan has
brought her a bit of time at least until
the end of the month and Liz truss's
allies feel that those trying to oust
her don't have a particular plan or a
particular candidate in mind to replace
her but as inflation now hits record
highs not seen for 40 years and with
tough spending decisions needing to be
made even pensions the NHS and schools
potentially not protected things aren't
going to get any easier okay for now
thank you
while the rate of inflation has returned
to double figures 10.1 percent last
month due to Rising food prices
um let's get more should we Emma
standing by for us in West London um hi
Emma where are you this morning
I'm at Western International Market in
Southall and it's a hive of activity the
doors here actually open at 2 A.M and
most of the people coming here are
shopkeepers and it won't come as a
surprise to them to hear these inflation
figures actually when it comes to food a
non-alcoholic drinks the increase is
14.6 it's the biggest increase since
April 1980 and it certainly isn't a
surprise to billu Bal you're the owner
of Exotica Subaru thank you so much for
joining us
tell us about how prices are going up
for example okra used to be about 12 14
to 15 pounds today's price is 21 pounds
papaya used to be 15 to 60 pounds today
we are selling for 30 pounds same with
the tomatoes so double the price to the
price is 10 pounds it used to be five to
six pound so all the exchange rate
that's why old everything's developed
the price is so I mean and what are
shopkeepers coming to you saying it's
still offering at the old prices
we are asking for 21 pounds so all the
rates are more than double but you can't
do that I guess they're asking for that
but you can't do it but we can't set in
for Less we can't put money from pocket
so we have to sell it for profit
people can't afford to buy food
that's what I think
you've got a restaurant as well our
electricity for a restaurant from 16p
doing it to 77 pounds 16 per units is 77
Pence unit for new contract okay all
right Billy Bell thank you very much for
joining us so I think what you can tell
there whether it's Energy prices whether
it's the prices of food
prices of mortgages for people all these
things everything going up a real impact
and it's going to be tough times ahead
okay thank you
well joining us now is the former member
of the bank of England's monetary policy
committee that's Andrew's sentence hello
to you Mr Center thanks for joining us
on the program this morning what do you
make of the figures
well they're no great surprise I think
everyone was expecting to think around
about 10
um it's done just above that 10.1
percent
I think the Striking thing about these
inflation figures now is inflation is
becoming more broadly based we've just
heard about uh food price inflation
um actually petrol prices which were
driving up inflation earlier this year
they've been coming down recently but
despite the fact they've been coming
down we've still got
um the highest rates of inflation that
we've had since the early 1980s
um so it does show that the inflation
problem is in danger of becoming more
deeply ingrained in the economy
what sit down too do you think you you
say petrol prices are coming down we've
just heard there what's happening as far
as food is concerned
well Energy prices have played a part
um and if we look back over the last
year uh particularly domestic energy
prices have gone up but
um I think the decline in the pound we
heard from that uh stall holder just now
uh saying that's been pushing up the
cost of imported foodstuffs and there's
just been a generalized increase in
costs with higher wages
um some other high costs per business
um and the combination of all those
things has brought us to an inflation
rate that's more than five times Bank
England's Target patients should be two
percent but now it's 10.1 percent
yeah
um how much high do you think it might
go
well we've got the um further rise in
Energy prices to come
um in the next uh couple of months uh
even though the government's putting a
cap on it uh they're still energy price
is going to go up
um earlier this year the bank said uh
they bought inflation go up to about 13
percent
um I think certainly it could go higher
um and it won't start coming down I
think significantly until when well into
next year
so you think inflation could go above 13
is that's what you're saying there
um I think we'll have to wait and see
the bank bank of England is making
another forecast at the beginning of
November uh we'll see what their latest
assessment is there's been a lot of
things changing such as the energy price
cap coming in so they will be able to
take all those factors into account
um but certainly uh there's a
significant risks that tend to go above
where it is now
interest rates than um and thus
mortgages
um destined to go higher as well from
what you're saying Andrew
yes I think um the markets are expecting
quite a big increase in interest rates
at the beginning of November uh possibly
as much as one percent which would be
the biggest rise we've had uh for a long
time
um and the reason for that is that
interest rates have been kept so low for
so long the bank of England is now
having to catch up
um with a situation of inflation which
they hadn't really anticipated so we're
probably going to see a couple of
further Rises uh this year take interest
rates I would think to
somewhere around about four percent by
early next year
wow goodness and then of course we we
know that that is even more as far as
mortgages uh interest rates are
concerned to what extent should the bank
of England have to accept some
responsibility for keeping interest
rates low for so long
well I think that's being a contributory
Factor um as we came out of the pandemic
uh the bank was quite slow in making any
increase in interest rates and they kept
their program of concept of easing
pumping money into the economy going
throughout last year and they only
raised interest rates for the first time
in December last year
um many people like myself were calling
for Rises interest rates much earlier uh
in 2021
uh if they've done that they might have
helped the situation it wouldn't have
prevented the whole of the spike in
inflation that we've seen but it might
have taken the edge off it and limited
the rate of inflation that we're now
seeing
um have you known a relationship between
the treasury and the bank of England as
bad as this one
well I'm not sure the relationship
between the treasury and the bank of
England
um is bad I think at a working level
um there's a lot of cooperation I think
uh what has made in life very difficult
was the mini budget which has now been
virtually scrapped
um and we've now got a Chancellor
um I think who is uh in a position to
work with the bank of England and
um all in the same direction the problem
we had after the mini budget was
while the bank of England was trying to
take money out of the economy and curb
inflation the government had a budget
which put an awful lot of money back
into the economy and so the treasury in
the Bank of England were pulling in
opposite directions
that's no longer the case and uh Jeremy
Hunt Chancellor yeah
um let's see what happens next and of
course uh his next fiscal announcement
on the 31st of October thanks very much
indeed thank you thanks a lot as I
talked to Wendy who's been raising her
two grandchildren amid the rising cost
of living hi Wendy it's good to talk to
you
um you've had to give up work haven't
you to look after your two grandchildren
tell me how you're coping
well I'm retired now but yes I did 14
years ago I was told if I wanted to be a
kinship carer then I would have to give
up work
okay and talk to me about the challenges
that that caused for you
uh well straight away you're down to a
single income because my husband's alive
then
um and yeah it was hard but we we got on
with it but now of course with the
rising inflation things are becoming
more difficult
yeah how old are the children know
um the oldest is 15 he'll be 16 at
Christmas and the youngest is 11 in
January oh lovely so there's I mean that
they're one of them is a a teenager the
other one's just uh dealing with all
those hormones and emotions how are they
coping with um the challenges that
you're all facing as a result of the
cost of living
it probably hasn't impacted on them yet
um there are small treats which we
normally had for granted you know I I
have to say well perhaps not like
literally going out and buying ice cream
when you're on a an outing for the day I
I have to bear in mind that one ice
cream from a an ice cream van is
probably equivalent to six from the
local supermarket
yeah yeah and those are the calculations
that you have to make for them
um what would it mean to you if the
government didn't honor its pledge uh to
keep pensions increasing with the rate
of inflation in other words if your
pension didn't go up 10 next year what
difference would that make to you
oh incredible because the price is
arising we're seeing the inflation now
coming up to double figures
um so that would really sort of keep us
on the level that we would learn now if
it went up but if it doesn't then of
course we've got to make even more
adjustments
yeah
um what do you think of Liz Tross
um early days yeah
did you like Boris Johnson
more Mike
but you liked him do you wish he was
still prime minister
I won't be drawn into that one sorry
okay
the reason I'm asking you is because
there's some poles out Wendy that is
just suggesting uh that a significant uh
minority of people want him to come back
and be prime minister I just wondered
whether you thought that would make any
difference to your income and your
pension
I don't think friends what the policies
would be now
um certainly anybody that supports
kinship carers and getting announced for
kinship carers has my vote yeah and tell
tell us a little bit more about kinship
care and what it actually involves
okay kinship care not a it's surprising
how few people actually know what
kinship care is uh kinship is where a
charm from within the family is brought
up by another relative for instance an
aunt and uncle cousin sibling or like
myself a grandparent when the parents
aren't able to but kinship is can also
be sort of a close friend or a neighbor
right okay
um and when you look back you know it
was a challenging time when you had to
take on you thought you brought up your
own children and then you were bringing
up your grandchildren so a different a
different a seismic shift in your life
but I'm sure that you wouldn't have done
anything differently would you
absolutely not no I'm sure well um I'm
sure that so Christmas time what when's
his birthday at Christmas
22nd of December oh I hope he gets one
present for Christmas and one present
for his birthday my my birthday is just
before Christmas and I was always told
when I was growing up this is for
Christmas and for your birthday
absolutely you've got Chad one for each
um one of the things if I could just say
you know we are running a petition
through kinship it's called value our
love and if people would please sign up
then perhaps other
um kinship carers who aren't actually
getting allowances
um will will be considered we don't get
an allowance not everybody gets an
allowance okay and uh one of those
things yeah very good case for that
Wendy
um so hopefully people will do that and
we appreciate you taking the time to
join us uh this morning
um keep well I hope the kids are okay
and we look forward to chatting to you
again soon thanks very much indeed for
joining us
thank you okay bye